I gotta get all tatted up bro I gotta
get all tatted up my tattoo artist is
always so busy though and going around
the world and [__] I want to get new
ones I got to get new ones I want to get
[__] tied up the other day the other
day I looked at myself I was clothed and
I was like wow it would be [__]
pretty ripping if something was peeking
out of my neckline like if I just had
some [__] like some wings or
something
I know I'm not I mean look I know I'm
gonna be 40 but I'm the young I'm also
the youngest man alive and bro that [__]
would look banging dude I need to get I
want to get a crown tattooed under my
hairline oh
dude do you know how much [__] you get
for real if you have a crown under your
hairline
not that I want you know I'm not hiding
on you know that's not me that's my
style but
wow dude
you just gotta be so comfortable and
also secretly uncomfortable to get a
tattoo bro how about Chris Brown gotta
[__] shoe on his cheek
and Chris Brown got a tattoo of a
[__] shoe on his cheek another guy
invented that shoe and then Chris Brown
got it on his face
such a beta [__] cuck move dude ew
you know
ew it's a Jordan three
that's why I got animals I got a plane
it doesn't have a [__] Delta symbol
on it you know
when you have [__] uh when you have a
thing on your on your thing it's weird
enough that guys had I that's why I got
it from Dr Wu because I wanted to I like
his art and I was like that's it that
you know I like his art whatever I'm the
same way I'm a [__] I might as well
got a tattoo of a shoe on my forehead
oh
but my point is I need more tattoos and
my my dude the dude who does it was
always in Japan or some [__]
I gotta get a new guy so who wants to
tattoo me man
um
but I only get like cool [__] sexy as
[__] [__]
I need something peeking out my neckline
dude
[Music]